voilà ils sont là
je voulais aussi vous chez notre
mannequin
moser voilà donc le masque se met
facilement sur le visage commission d'un
autre masque qui est relié au fait un
générateur de pression et une turbine et
en a au dessus du masque donc la
connexion de l'arrivée de la pression et
de l'autre côté
en fait la sortie des gaz qui vont être
expulsés vers la pièce alors on ya mis
un filtre qui va filtrer les particules
virales qui sont expirés par le patient
et au delà on a une valve à l'entrée de
surpression de la permettre de garder à
l'intérieur du masque plus tard
direction positive
là où le subtil ans restera donc cette
idée c'est pas nous qui l'avons eu au
départ ce sont des italiens qui ont
cherché des alternatives justement à la
pénurie de masques qu'ils avaient envie
tally et qui ont développé une première
une première connexion pour le masque
décathlon qui est cette valve aussi
qu'on appelle la valve de charlotte nous
elle nous a semblé assez compliqué à
fabriquer assez lourde
pas très commode et donc on a eu l'idée
de pousser un tout petit peu plus loin
la réflexion et de développer nous mêmes
notre protection
l'indication principale ce sont des
patients qui ont une atteinte
respiratoire sévère
le but est d'éviter de devoir un tube et
la trachée du patient et le maître
respirateur il ya une pénurie de
respirateurs on a lancé aussi des idées
un petit peu de constructions de
respirateurs un peu dans tous les pays
le but est quand même d'essayer de ne
pas arriver à la dégradation ultime qui
nécessitent la mise du patient
respiratory